c'est l'heure de notre second débat tout
de suite évidemment il nous emmène comme
je vous le disais en titre en Chine
dimanche le 20e congrès du Parti
communiste chinois s'est ouvert sur un
tonnerre d'applaudissements pour le
secrétaire général si Jean Ping il est
en route pour un troisième mandat et
montre sa force notamment à propos de la
petite île voisine de Taïwan Fabien
ovationné par les 2300 délégués du Parti
communiste chinois à 69 ans il devrait
devenir le premier dirigeant du pays
depuis Mao a enchaîné un troisième
mandat consécutif après avoir modifié en
2018 la Constitution pour supprimer la
limite de deux mandats présidentielles
dans son discours si Jean Ping a appelé
à l'unité l'ensemble du parti et le
peuple de toutes les ethnies sont
engagés sur la voie de la construction
d'un pays socialiste moderne avec pour
ambition de faire de la Chine la
première puissance mondiale en 2049 date
du centenaire de la Révolution si Jean
Ping inventé la modernité chinoise comme
une alternative au camp occidental avec
lequel les relations se sont dégradées
sous son règne principal allié de la
Russie devenant Poutine en compétition
commerciale avec les États-Unis
a dénoncé les ingérences étrangères dans
le dossier de Taïwan laissant planer la
menace d'un recours à la force la
résolution de la question de Taiwan et
l'affaire du peuple chinois lui-même et
elle doit être résolue par le peuple
chinois seul nous œuvrerons avec la plus
grande sincérité et les plus grands
efforts pour une réunification pestif de
Taïwan mais nous ne renoncerons jamais
au recours à la force sur le plan
intérieur doit pourtant faire face à un
ralentissement de la croissance chinoise
et au mécontentement suscité par sa
politique zéro covid Ferrari SIM en
marge du congrès une banderole dénonçant
le régime a été accroché à ce pont de
Pékin avant d'être rapidement retiré le
Congrès doit se poursuivre à huis clos
jusqu'au 22 octobre après quoi le Comité
central désignera la nouvelle équipe
dirigeante avec à sa tête sans nul doute
le désormais tout puissant si Jean Bing
le pouvoir de Killing ping voilà ce dont
on débat tout de suite avec mes invités
et le virfabry bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes chercheur à l'Institut Jacques
Delore rapporteur de l'étude construire
l'autonomie stratégique de l'Europe face
à la Chine j'accueille également
Jean-Philippe déjà bonsoir vous êtes
sinologue directeur de recherche et
mérite au CNRS chercheurs au Centre
d'études et de recherche internationale
série Sciences Po pirates qui bonsoir
vous êtes chroniqueur géopolitique pour
France Inter et l'obser ancien
correspondant en Chine laetitia cruppa
est resté à mes côtés peut-être pour
commencer le virturé comment on peut
qualifier le pouvoir de XX Jinping
aujourd'hui c'est un dictateur un
autocrate quel terme vous pourriez
employer ecoutez le sentiment c'est que
le sentiment qu'on a c'est qu'il n'a
fait que renforcer sa capacité de
contrôle au sein du parti et le rôle du
parti au sein de la société chinoise
donc oui on a le sentiment quand même
aujourd'hui d'un psy qui est
relativement isolé dans sa capacité à
prendre des décisions à maintenir
aujourd'hui un cap économique dont on
voit qu'il est
qui
on a une croissance économique en berne
on a une une population chinoise qui a
un moral qui est chaque jour un peu plus
bas et pourtant qu'il maintient ce cap
parce qu'il a décidé que c'était d'abord
l'idéologie qui primait et que c'est les
choix qu'il a qu'il avait adopté il est
déjà il y a quelques années sur la façon
de gérer la pandémie la politique du
zéro covid le maintien des contrôles
tout ça même si le bilan aujourd'hui est
très sévère il maintient ce cap et donc
ce que l'on peut dire c'est que
l'équation c'est qu'il a une capacité de
contrôle qui reste peut contesté au sein
du parti Jean-Philippe déjà si on si on
parle un peu du personnage et de son
histoire c'est un pur produit du du
système communiste j'ai lu que ses
parents faisaient même partie des des
fondateurs de la République populaire de
Chine aux côtés de Mao en 49
le père de Céline a accueilli
au lendemain de la longue marche donc en
1935 puisqu'il était responsable des
dirigeants de la base communiste de Yann
nord-ouest de la Chine donc on peut dire
que c'est un ancien de de la révolution
sans aucun doute mais justement
l'arrivée de Céline pig au pouvoir avait
fait naître beaucoup d'espoir pourquoi
parce que son père si jeanxieux a été
critiqué en 1962 il a perdu son poste et
pendant la Révolution culturelle sidine
lui-même qui était tout petit il avait
qu'il avait 15 ans a été envoyé à la
campagne il est revenu de la campagne et
il a été emprisonné par les garde-rouges
il a été largement critiqué sa
demi-soeur s'est suicidé et ensuite il a
été renvoyé à la campagne j'allais dire
peu poliment à coup de pied dans les
fesses par ses parents et là il est
resté et à ce moment-là il a fait 7 fois
sa demande d'entrer aux parties à la
huitième fois il a été pris et à partir
de là on a qui change complètement mais
il y a une espoir qui puisse réformer un
peu tenir compte de sa propre histoire
de sa famille pour pour assouplir le
régime j'étais en 2012 au moment du 17e
du 18e congrès quand il allait arriver
et dans les milieux dissidents et dans
les milieux libéraux il y avait un grand
espoir il avait été jeune instruit il
avait vu la la terrible condition de vie
dans les campagnes chinoises et le
nord-ouest de la Chine je vais vous dire
c'est pas particulièrement avancé il
avait été victime son père avait été
victime des deux purges et d'autre part
après sa réhabilitation son père si
Johnson a été l'un des fondateurs de la
fameuse zone économique spéciale de
Shanghai qui était donc l'ouverture de
la Chine au capitalisme et en plus après
le massacre du 4 juin
1989 il a été sur la touche pour cette
opposée il était mis sur la touche pour
cette opposé à l'intervention de l'armée
tout le monde le savait dans surtout
dans les milieux des des Princes rouges
et donc on s'attendait à ce que une fois
arrivé au pouvoir il soit justement
quelqu'un qui approfondisse les réformes
et qui comprennent l'importance de la du
d'une autonomie de la société pour se
régime qu'est-ce qui s'est passé alors
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé alors on va
dire la parole juste après parce
qu'effectivement ça va faire pardon
Laetitia et ça va faire partie des des
éléments de ce débat mais je voudrais
entendre pierre à ski peut-être sur sur
un premier bilan je crois qu'il avait
révélé sa doctrine il avait dit le rêve
chinois alors bon on peut dire ça tous
les hommes politiques peuvent arriver
avec un rêve pour leur pays mais quel
bilan vous en faites 10 ans plus tard il
a
renforcé ça a été dit le contrôle et le
pouvoir absolu non seulement du parti ce
qui est très important parce que
en Chine c'est le parti qui a qui a
l'ascendance sur l'état et donc c'est le
parti qui qui dicte tout mais il a
renforcé son pouvoir personnel il y
avait une doctrine était celle de dencia
Hawking après après les excès de la
période Mao et Xiaoping avait vanté les
mérites de la collégialité et ça a
fonctionné jusqu'à simping simping a
cassé cette collégialité pour avoir un
pouvoir personnel on le surnommait au
début le président de tout parce que dès
qu'il y avait le moindre comité qui
était créé il en était le président donc
il est il a tout centralisé autour de sa
personne donc de ce point de vue là il a
il a réussi cette OPA sur le sur le
parti et sur et sur le pouvoir chinois
de l'autre côté le bilan et ça a été dit
tout à l'heure et beaucoup plus mitigé
parce que il se retrouve aujourd'hui par
ses choix
aussi bien ceux de l'expansion
internationale et de et d'une
affirmation internationale de la Chine
avec des problèmes qui sont
considérables cette opposition frontale
avec les États-Unis est quand même en
partie dû au fait que la Chine et
afficher un peu trop vite euh ses
ambitions de devenir le numéro un
mondial dans tous les secteurs et
aujourd'hui se retrouve avec cette
convergence de crise le covid le zéro
covid qui est un une sorte de sparadrate
dont il n'arrive pas à se débarrasser il
pensait avoir le meilleur bilan au monde
sur le covid et il a aujourd'hui une
population qui n'en peut plus
l'économie est aujourd'hui
inférieur à la moyenne asiatique c'est
la première fois depuis 30 ans que c'est
comme ça que la Chine n'est plus le
moteur la locomotive de de la croissance
économique et le troisième problème
c'est son soutien et son à sa proximité
avec Poutine sur la guerre d'Ukraine qui
aujourd'hui est une source d'embarras
aussi parce que deux semaines avant
l'invasion de l'Ukraine Poutine était à
Pékin signé avec sitting une déclaration
promettant une amitié sans limite sans
limite et aujourd'hui on le voit bien la
Chine est et à la fois dans le soutien
politique mais elle ne se mouille pas
plus que ça dans le soutien concret à la
Russie alors il y a plusieurs éléments
dans ce que vous venez de nous dire il y
a notamment la politique zéro covid on y
reviendra évidemment le le
l'alliance peut-être pas le meilleur
terme mais entre la Chine et la et la
Russie en tout cas la proximité affichée
mais il y a effectivement cette question
du bilan économique et là les ici sièges
me tournent vers vous parce que il y a
un détail qui a attiré votre attention
aujourd'hui le Bureau National des
Statistiques devais dévoiler une série
d'indicateurs économiques dont le
chiffre de la croissance pour juillet
septembre ça a été reporté
parce que c'est la deuxième fois en très
peu de temps que Pékin repousse ciné Dié
hein l'annonce de ces chiffres vendredi
dernier la Chine avait déjà reporté sans
donner de raison la publication des
chiffres du commerce pour le mois de
septembre et c'est tout à fait
inhabituel pourquoi parce que d'habitude
les chiffres servent à asseoir le
pouvoir de la deuxième puissance
économique mondiale
pas mauvais ces chiffres évidemment on
pense tous que ils sont mauvais enfin
tous les experts en tout cas on a quand
même quelques indications par exemple
ceux du deuxième trimestre le PIB avait
progressé seulement de
0,4% par an pire performance depuis 2020
et puis il y a aussi par exemple les
chiffres des douanes chinoises ou on
voit que l'économie tourne au ralenti
les importations les exportations ont
connu au mois d'août un être
ralentissement alors il y a un groupe de
12 experts qui ont été rassemblés pour
essayer comme ça de d'imaginer quel
serait ces chiffres et il tape tout sur
une croissance de
2,5% pour ce troisième trimestre et pour
3% ensuite pour 2023 ce qui serait le
rythme le plus faible depuis 40 ans
juste pour vous donner un ordre d'idée
pk lui enfin si Jean pi avait établi sur
5,5 % de croissance et quand on dit
5,5% quand le parti du sale les
entreprises ont intérêt à suivre et donc
évidemment en plein 20e congrès c'est
pas le moment de dévoiler ces chiffres
non bien compris il ne faut pas venir
perturber le couronnement de Jean Ping
d'autant que c'est mauvais chiffres
pourraient venir on l'a dit là de sa
politique zéro covid on peut pas
imaginer comment les Chinois vivent
depuis 3 ans nous qui avons pris la
décision nous quand j'ai nous les pays
occidentaux et puis tout le reste du
monde de vivre avec le virus il continue
à être poursuivi à être le cloitré et
fatalement l'économie en subit les
conséquences par exemple les ventes
immobilières qui représentent un gros
secteur du PIB sont en net recul est-ce
qu'il y a aussi une guerre cachée dont
on peut parler entre les Américains et
les Chinois dans le domaine de la tech
oui parce que c'est la flèche
empoisonnée qui a envoyé Joe Biden juste
avant l'ouverture du 20e congrès du PC
chinois un document d'une centaine de
pages qui établit des restrictions alors
c'est assez technique c'est sûr les
semis conducteurs ces petites puces
électronique indispensable à notre ère
numérique et qui est à des secteurs
pionniers de la Chine donc pas vraiment
de hasard dans ce timing c'est un
message politique qui est envoyé par les
États-Unis peut-être pour peut-être
probablement même pour la question de
Taïwan en tout cas c'est un
avertissement si vous touchez à Taïwan
si vous avancez d'un pas l'économie en
tout cas pour vous sera encore plus
difficile c'est Joe Biden qui le
sous-entend
Jean-Philippe déjà alors ça a peut-être
vous permettre de répondre en partie à
qui se posait les 17 à tout à l'heure
c'est voilà c'est mauvais chiffre même
s'ils sont pas publiés ils sont connus
ils sont connus de des cercles du
pouvoir chinois pour pourquoi ça ne
fragilise pas plus que ça le pouvoir de
psy parce que l'essentiel n'est pas là
pour céder une fille on a fait une
translation de légitimité si vous
regardez le rapport au 20e congrès
l'économie n'est pas du tout au centre
de l'affaire ce qui est au centre c'est
la sécurité nationale et profondeur de
la Chine et c'est cela l'important est
le renforcement du pouvoir du Parti il
faut bien voir les chiffres n'ont pas
été publiés c'est vrai maintenant vous
savez les chiffres du bureau national
des statistiques quand même c'est on ne
peut plus manipuler les chiffres du
bureau national des statistiques c'est
évidemment le symbole de quelque chose
qui se passe à l'intérieur de l'appareil
d'État chinois comme on le disait tout à
l'heure c'est un des paris qui est de
plus en plus opaque on n'a jamais été si
peu au fait de ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur du système de pouvoir que
depuis l'accession au pouvoir de Céline
pic et notamment depuis son deuxième
mandat donc simplement le fait de ne pas
publier ces chiffres est un signe qui
vient qu'il y a peut-être un certain
nombre de divergences et on pense
immédiatement à les chrétien qui devrait
partir à l'issue de ce congrès
qui est le oui bien sûr c'est tout à
fait vous voyez c'est très clair c'est
le numéro 2 c'est le premier ministre
vous connaissez l'iPad vous aviez
entendu parler de Georgia mais vous ne
connaissez pas l'icotien parce que
depuis que si est arrivé au pouvoir les
chrétiens n'a été complètement mis sur
la touche alors il a pas beaucoup de
pouvoir mais il représente une des
factions pour revenir à ce que vous me
disiez tout à l'heure pourquoi a-t-il
changé alors quand il est arrivé au
pouvoir si Jean Ping c'est un homme de
compromis ça rappelait quelque chose
vous allez voir
il y avait plusieurs factions à
l'intérieur du parti communiste il y a
toujours des factions à l'intérieur du
parti communiste on avait souvent il y
en avait soudain il y en avait après sur
routine
Japon donc ce qui se passe c'est que les
fractions la faction des princes et la
faction de la Ligue de la jeunesse il
tient ce mec d'accord pour mettre au
pouvoir quelqu'un qui semble au fond
assez peu assez phalot donc on va le
mettre et on pourra continuer parce que
il faut bien voir qu'à ce moment-là le
la partie n'est pas très unie ça part un
peu plus dans tous les sens la direction
collective fait qu'on ne peut pas avoir
de grandes initiatives parce qu'il faut
se mettre d'accord or il y a des
conflits entre les divers groupes
d'intérêts alors on va mettre ceci
Jinping et on va continuer comme avant
et qu'est-ce qui fait en arrivant il dit
je vais faire une grande campagne contre
la correction tout le monde est toujours
d'accord pour lutter contre la
corruption c'est populaire c'est bien
etc et puis la campagne que j'ai contre
la corruption est dure depuis 10 ans ça
d'habitude ça marche pas d'habitude ça
dure 1 an 2 ans et puis on se remet
servi pour pour faire le ménagement
etc et ben c'est que tu es un peu comme
un certain Joseph visalionovic Staline
qui était arrivé personne on disait il y
avait trop de ski qui était quand même
un grand orateur en Chine on avait bossé
la qui était un personnage au grand
cariste et puis on arrive et qu'est-ce
qu'on utilise alors on dit beaucoup
c'est d'une fille c'est le nouveau
manque non pas du tout Simpson c'est un
nouveau Staline c'est-à-dire que il va
utiliser cette campagne contre la
corruption pour vous débarrasser de ces
de ses de ses adversaires potentiels et
comment est-ce qu'il va le faire non pas
en faisant appel au largement
pour le pendant la Révolution culturelle
mais on utilisant la commission centrale
de contrôle de la discipline dirigé par
son numéro 2 à l'époque
et avec ça il va se débarrasser quand
même de 53 cadres du niveau national et
de 5 millions de cadres du parti c'est à
dire c'est quelque chose d'énorme cette
campagne et donc avec les là il va
récupérer le pouvoir réunifier le parti
c'est très important il aura une
véritable ligne mais il y a une autre
chose ce qui vient de faire là au moment
au mois de septembre simplement au mois
de septembre juste à la veille de ce
congrès il a fait qu'on n'a pas
peut-être pas lu pardon les tribunaux
chinois ont condamné à la peine de mort
avec un sursis de deux ans deux
personnes foutent en croix et solide qui
sont les deux vis ministres alors un
ministre de la Justice et l'autre était
vice-ministre de la sécurité comme ayant
fait la clique de la sécurité publique
pour s'opposer à ces jeans ces deux
personnes sont ceux qui l'ont le plus
aidé à se débarrasser de ces révoles là
encore ça rappelle quand même quelque
chose il y avait un certain Liégeois qui
au lendemain de la tirof avait aidé
Staline a renforcer son pouvoir et il
s'en est débarrassé c'est une fille qui
fait un peu pareil mais c'est une
histoire d'isolement qu'on est en train
de de raconter finalement elle vire
Fabri d'un homme qui est de plus en plus
isolé alors on va revenir aux
contre-pouvoirs qui peuvent exister ou
pas au sein du Parti communiste chinois
mais je voudrais quand même rester sur
le la thématique de la faiblesse de
l'économie chinoise parce que c'est pas
forcément une bonne nouvelle pour nous
pour les Européens parce que c'est quand
même un des moteurs de la croissance
mondiale laquelle de nos économies
européennes est la plus dépendante de la
Chine d'une certaine façon c'est
l'Allemagne je crois c'est
a construit tout son modèle de
développement économique des 30
dernières années sur le l'intégration
des chaînes de production à la
production à l'usine chinoise donc à
l'importe des pièces détachées elle
importe des biens intermédiaires qu'elle
monte notamment toute la machine riz
allemande toute l'industrie lourde et
elle réexporte parce que c'est aussi la
demande chinoise qui intéresse les
Allemands et aujourd'hui c'est toutes
les les grandes les grands constructeurs
automobiles allemands investissent en
Chine il faut savoir une chose c'est que
là les chiffres de l'investissement
européen en Chine sont essentiellement
faits par 10 grandes entreprises sur les
1800 entreprises présentes européennes
présentes en Chine il y en a 10 qui font
80% de l'investissement de la dernière
année et sur ces 10 grosses entreprises
il y en a cinq qui sont allemandes donc
c'est vraiment le l'ancrage l'ancrage
allemand qui est déterminant et
l'Allemagne actuellement est en train de
préparer une partager Chine qui aura un
impact sur le débat sur le débat
européen mais oui pour revenir au
signaux que nous envoient cette économie
chinoise en berne
on les Européens comme comme les
américains les Japonais regardent ça en
effet de très près parce que ce que l'on
voit c'est que la machine économique
chinoise est en train de se gripper
notamment parce que tout le moteur de la
construction immobilière tout le secteur
immobilier qui représentait 25 30% du
pipe est en train de se bloquer avec la
crise immobilière c'était toute la
source d'enrichissement des Chinois donc
c'était toute le tout ce qui tout ce qui
tenait le formidable accélération de de
l'économie chinoise et que par ailleurs
là alors que si jimping a décidé de
dépendre moins de de ces importations de
produits venant du reste du monde mais
au contraire d'accroître la dépendance
des pays tiers
il commence à y avoir là une conscience
plus aiguë des problèmes de dépendance
stratégique dépendance excessive à des
produits spécifiques chinois et avec
autant du côté américain du côté
européen du côté japonais ou autre le la
conscience qu'il faut rééquilibrer
certains échanges alors que nous
européens nous avons eu tendance à
renforcer très fortement notre
intégration à ces chaînes de valeur pas
simplement les les Allemands le volume
d'ensemble des échanges commerciaux le
montre l'immobilier pire à ce qui
c'était c'était un peu le rêve de la
classe moyenne chinoise je sais pas si
on peut dire ça mais et ça m'amène à une
question sur le le contre-pouvoir ou
l'opinion publique chinoise on a vu dans
le reportage furtivement un bannière de
d'opposition qui avait été affiché je
pense qu'il faut juste se poser pour
imaginer le courage de celui ou celle
qui a osé faire ça dans le régime
chinois de d'aujourd'hui mais est-ce que
il y a malgré tout voilà des des voix
qui s'élèvent peut-être
peut-être dans les cercles du pouvoir
pour dire mais voilà le moteur est en
train de s'arrêter la politique du tout
contrôle à des limites le la stratégie
zéro covid a montré à montrer ses
limites aussi écouter dès son arrivée au
pouvoir en 2012 c'était une pink a
casser ce qui restait de société civile
naissante en Chine depuis le début des
années 2000 on a un espace qui s'est
constitué avec un secteur associatif des
avocats par exemple qui était une part
importante de cette société civile etc
ça a été complètement cassé c'est à dire
qu'il a il y avait une directive interne
du parti qui listait les secteurs les
ennemis de du parti dans lequel il y
avait le concept de société civile qui
était pour lui le cheval de troie de
l'Occident en gros et donc dès le début
les contre-pouvoirs potentiels parce que
ils étaient loin de constituer des
contre-pouvoirs et ont été la de Sitting
et puis vous avez eu ces dernières
années une campagne contre les grands
capitaines d'industrie le plus connu et
le premier qui a été visé c'était jackma
Jackman fondateur du groupe Alibaba qui
est à géant une capitalisation boursière
qui est à peu près équivalente de Google
ou d'Amazon et qui s'est retrouvé à
disparaître comme on dit en Chine
pendant plusieurs semaines parce qu'il
avait fait un discours qui critiquait le
secteur bancaire étatique disparaître ça
veut dire que vous êtes entre les mains
de la police du parti donc dans un
général il vous êtes dans un une sorte
d'hôtel en résidence surveillée
interrogé etc c'est ce qu'on appelle des
prisons noirs aussi et le et tous les
grands groupes privés chinois ont été la
cible du pouvoir c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
eu
une tentative d'empêcher c'est ce
secteur privé avec des gens
puissant extrêmement riche mais aussi
très connu à l'étranger jackma a fait
des débats avec Obama au Forum de Davos
et des choses comme ça donc c'était un
statut qui pouvait faire de l'ombre et
c'est une ping et ils ont été cassés les
uns après les autres et aujourd'hui on a
et on le voit il y a dans les traces
dans le dans le rapport au congrès du
parti on est dans une réétatisation très
forte de l'économie le secteur privé a
le droit d'exister mais il est soumis
aux intérêts de l'État et du parti et
c'est le secteur public donc le secteur
étatique capitalisme d'État qui est le
centre le cœur névralgique de l'économie
chinoise alors je récompense de Taïwan
maintenant et je propose à Steve
Jourdain de nous rejoindre les tensions
autour de
Taïwan petit île voisine de de la Chine
on peut dire que si Jean Ping maintient
la pression oui la Chine ne renoncera
jamais à l'usage de la force
besoin si besoin c'est ce qui a déclaré
le dirigeant chinois lors de son
discours dimanche dernier l'île de
Taïwan se considère depuis 1949 comme la
seule et véritable République de Chine
mais la Chine communiste elle ne le voit
pas du même œil elle considère que
Taïwan fait partie de son territoire à
ce sujet si j'ai une pink a rappelé
dimanche la position de Pékin écouter le
face aux activités sécessionnistes des
forces indépendantistes taïwanaises et
au graphes provocation des forces
extérieures qui s'immises dans les
affaires de Taïwan nous avons mené
résolument une lutte contre le
séparatisme et l'ingérence et démontrer
notre détermination et notre capacité à
sauvegarder la souveraineté nationale
l'intégrité territoriale et à nous
opposer à l'indépendance de Taïwan
est-ce qu'une invasion chinoise de
Taïwan est envisable elle est en tout
cas clairement envisagée du côté
taiwanais le rapport de force et
évidemment disproportionné on va voir
quelques chiffres Taïwan c'est 23
millions d'habitants une armée modeste
de 169.000 militaires d'actifs qui veut
quand même compter sur plus d'un million
500000 réservistes en face et bien il y
a la Chine et c'est un milliard 400 000
habitants qui comptent sur une armée de
2 millions de soldats dont près d'un
million pour la seule armée de terre
dans ces conditions et bien la
présidente de Taïwan réélu pour un
deuxième mandat en 2020 tente de prendre
la communauté internationale à témoins
écouter c'était lors de la Journée
nationale du pays c'était la semaine
dernière
la communauté internationale comprend
parfaitement que le maintien de la
sécurité de Taïwan signifie le maintien
de la stabilité régionale et des valeurs
démocratiques la destruction de la
démocratie et de la liberté de Taïwan
serait une grave défaite pour les
démocraties du monde
que peut la France dans ce conflit on a
on n'a pas je crois de relation
diplomatique avec Taïwan officiellement
Paris d'entretien pas de relation avec
l'île mais officieusement des échanges
existent bien il y en a même beaucoup
notamment en matière économique et
scientifiques un chiffre pour vous
montrer Thomas l'importance de Taïwan
dans l'économie mondiale Lille produit
près de 60% des semi-conducteurs de la
planète il s'agit de ces puces
électronique indispensable pour les
voitures les avions les smartphones et
qui dit en jeu économiques dit
évidemment intérêt politique pour
l'Occident et parlementaire se rendent
régulièrement sur l'île on va voir ces
images du groupe d'amitié France Taïwan
au Sénat images de la télévision
taiwanais c'était début septembre 5
sénateurs ont été accueillis par les
autorités locales parmi eux Olivier
Cadix le vice-président de la commission
des affaires étrangères au Sénat
c'est un modèle qui fonctionne bien le
pays se développe de façon
impressionnante c'est aujourd'hui la 21e
puissance économique dans le monde c'est
bientôt le G20 pour Taïwan et donc c'est
à eux de déterminer quel est leur avenir
se déplacement sur les autres c'était
une façon pour les élus français de
rappeler que Taïwan n'est pas seul face
au volonté expansionniste de la chimie
merci Steve et c'est bien 1 milliard 400
millions d'habitants en Chine on avait
rectifié de nous-mêmes je voudrais vous
entendre sur la question des
semi-conducteurs parce que c'est c'est
venu plusieurs fois finalement déjà dans
dans le débat
pourquoi je reviens à ce que Joe bidon
fait ça juste avant le le 20e congrès
c'est quoi la stratégie
c'est clairement une façon de chercher à
déstabiliser à envoyer un signal très
fort très offensif surtout que il faut
préciser que là le gouvernement
américain a appelé en un soir avec une
échéance tombant à Minuit le soir même
à ce que toutes les citoyens américains
qui travaillent d'une façon ou d'une
autre pour des entreprises chinoises sur
des technologies liées au
semi-conducteur donne leur démission
instantanément sans quoi ils perdaient
leur nationalité américaine ce qui a
donné lieu à une succession de
évidemment de démission et là ce que ça
veut dire c'est que les liens sont
enfin l'offensive est très forte le
signal est très fort et puis surtout là
le message est adressé à la Chine mais
ce que l'on voit c'est que les
États-Unis sont déjà en train d'exercer
de monter en pression vis-à-vis de leur
autre partenaire pour qu'il s'aligne sur
sur cette stratégie et l'objectif là
c'est de d'empêcher que la Chine fasse
des progrès dans ce secteur en matière
de semi-conducteur alors que elle est là
pour le moment une capacité de
production de 5% de ses besoins qu'elle
a elle s'est donnée à un objectif d'ici
2025 de monter en puissance à 25%, mais
que
la capacité d'innovation qu'elle a reste
encore relativement limité et c'est
cette c'est cette espèce de de SAS que
les États-Unis aimeraient pouvoir créer
en essayant de contenir plus
généralement l'essor de l'économie
chinoise à travers cet enjeu des
semi-conducteurs qu'on retrouve
maintenant dans toutes les dans toutes
les technologies et on voit
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une question aussi
que se pose les Européens pour essayer
de diversifier leur approvisionnement et
renforcer leur propre capacités de
production pire à ski si on parle de de
Taïwan est-ce qu'on peut dire que c'est
une obsession pour le régime chinois
c'est une blessure non refermée puisque
en 49 lorsque Mao prend le pouvoir à
Pékin il y a le le petit bout le village
Astérix de la Chine qui est qui résiste
et c'est là que ce réfugient check avec
l'armée des fêtes dans la guerre civile
chinoise et pendant deux décennies on a
une volonté de Mao de prendre Taïwan et
une volonté de tchangaecheck de
reprendre la Chine parce que il faut
quand même se mettre dans cet esprit que
tu engagek est arrivé à Taïwan en
pensant qu'il allait reconquérir le
continent qu'il attendait son heure et
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui c'est très
difficile à comprendre mais le les gens
qui sont au pouvoir à Taïwan et qui
s'appuient aujourd'hui sur un sentiment
majoritaire dans l'île ne veulent plus
reconquérir la Chine ils veulent qu'on
leur laisse la paix et il y a un
sentiment taïwanais qui a remplacé un
sentiment chinois quand vous demandez il
y a des sondages qui sont fait
régulièrement sur comment les gens se
définissent aujourd'hui 80% des
taïwanais se disent d'abord taïwanais et
auparavant ils disaient taïwanais
chinois ou chinois aujourd'hui il y a un
sentiment majoritaire qui est de prendre
le large et un des éléments déclencheur
de cette de cette prise de distance
c'est évidemment ce qui s'est passé à
Hong Kong parce que à Hong Kong la Chine
s'était engagée à ce système qu'on un
pays de système donc vous êtes dans la
République populaire mais vous avez
votre autonomie pendant 50 ans vous avez
vos institutions votre liberté
d'expression votre Parlement votre
justice indépendante etc au bout de 25
ans la Chine s'est assise sur ce traité
et elle a normalisé comme on dit
la société
hongkongaise aujourd'hui toute vitesse
avec une loi sur la sécurité nationale
qui est aujourd'hui le verrou de Hong
Kong ça a permis à la réélection de
timing la présidente de Taïwan ce
qu'elle n'était pas forcément en très
bonne posture et il y a eu un RAZ barré
pour elle parce que les Taïwanais se
sont dit mais c'est ça les promesses
chinoises puisque la Chine propose à
Taïwan le même principe un pays de
système vous revenez dans la mer patrie
et vous pouvez garder aux institutions
démocratiques si ça vous fait plaisir
bon personne n'y croit aujourd'hui à
Taïwan et c'est une partie de l'enjeu et
et il y a une sorte de d'enjeu national
existentielle que qui a été
exacerbé par les dirigeants chinois
depuis longtemps c'est une pin y a
ajouté une couche supplémentaire en
disant il ne l'a pas répété dans ce
discours là mais il l'avait dit dans un
précédent discours on ne peut pas se
permettre de renvoyer de génération en
génération la solution du problème de
Taïwan ce qui voulait dire qu'il allait
la régler de son vivant en tout cas
pendant son passage au pouvoir lequel
passage au pouvoir est aujourd'hui
prolongé
aussi longtemps que qu'il est en vie
mais
c'est c'est là qui a une équation un peu
compliquée moi je personnellement je ne
crois pas à une invasion proche de
Taïwan je pense que la stratégie
chinoise est que Taïwan tombe comme un
fruit mûr d'où leur colère chaque fois
que des délégations politiques vont à
Taïwan d'antipelosis évidemment plus que
plus que les sénateurs français soyons
modestes ça a pas vu pas eu le même
impact intern mais il y a cette idée que
il faut couper les liens politiques
entre Taïwan et le reste du monde pour
qu'un jour ça tombe comme un fruit
Jean-Philippe déjà qu'est-ce qui est
insupportable c'est cette îlot de
démocratie
voilà chez un tout petit voisin on a on
a revu la carte en a rappelé les
chiffres enfin bon c'est un supportable
quand on a besoin que ce soit
insupportable c'est pas ça pas toujours
été le cas dans les années 80 il y a eu
un énorme rapprochement entre le
continent et Taïwan les échanges
économiques c'est une chose qu'on oublie
peut-être mais quand on parle de guerre
etc les échanges économiques entre Pékin
et Taïwan sont extrêmement importants il
y a un million de taiwanais qui sont
installés en Chine qui travaillent en
Chine qui ont des usines en Chine il
faut bien voir que le grand don la
région de Schengen et la région de
Shanghai sont bourrés d'entreprises
taïwanaises donc si vous voulez
regardons les yeux des choses de manière
un petit peu plus objective quand on
veut on a dit tout à l'heure si Jean
Ping a abandonné l'idée de fonder la
légitimité du parti essentiellement sur
le développement économique donc sur
quoi est-ce qu'ils le font faire de la
Chine un pays et prospère le vieux rêve
chinois alors là c'est pas le rêve
chinois c'est d'une fille c'est le rêve
chinois de toutes les élites chinoises
depuis la guerre de l'opium en tout cas
depuis la guerre sino-japonaise de 1895
alors donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut et ben
il faut que ce soit une Chine unie pour
que la Chine soit forte elle doit être
unie qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on veut
mobiliser le nationalisme pour dire il
faut récupérer Taïwan alors l'histoire
quand on nous dit et nous ne renoncerons
pas à la force militaire comme si
c'était quelque chose qui depuis la
guerre de l'Ukraine donc devient quelque
chose d'énorme et de tout à fait nouveau
dans la politique chinoise regardez tous
les discours de tous les secrétaires
généraux du Parti communiste chinois
depuis 1949 nous ne renoncerons jamais à
la force pour récupérer Taïwan donc si
vous voulez aujourd'hui c'est un moyen
de mobiliser le nationalisme le
patriotisme comme dit
contre dans une grande lutte et puis
d'autre part il y a la question de la
sécurité nationale alors les étrangers
qui ont déjà
cassés complètement en compte qui ont
utilisé Hong Kong pour déstabiliser le
régime chinois et ben il continue comme
ils peuvent plus faire à Hong Kong ils
le font à Taïwan
on l'a bien compris
dans la réalité ce qui se passe c'est
que Hong Kong par exemple quand on a
fait des sondages auprès des moins de 25
ans il y en a deux pourcents qui
s'identifient à la Chine qui se disent
chinois 2%. alors que le le rêve de
dangstering c'était que la génération
naît après 1997 serait patriotique or
c'est le contraire qui s'est passé le
Parti communiste chinois fait peur il
fait peur aux gens à Hong Kong et il
fait peur aux gens à Taïwan comme le
disait très justement pierre Aski ça y
est one doit à la politique de sites
INPI à Hong Kong sa réélection elle
était en très plus postures en 2020 en
2019 et elle a été réélu donc
aujourd'hui si vous voulez il faut
mobiliser le nationalisme alors contre
les minorités qui sont en train de de
disrupter comme dit notre président
launi l'unité nationale de la Chine et
contre les Taïwanais qui sont en fait
une une base avancée des occidentaux
pour mettre à terme à la montée en
puissance de la Chine
parce que il s'en serviront comme d'un
objet pour justement que les Chinois
soient pas très ratés
qui peuvent qui peuvent en effet être
variés comme le disait pierre ASCII il
peut y avoir en effet inoffensive
militaire il faut pas exclure le
scénario mais ça peut être aussi un
scénario de blocus économique et ce que
l'on voit dans les manœuvres de ces
dernières semaines
à la fois maritime et aérienne autour de
le Taïwan c'est que finalement ce
scénario de blocus qui permettrait de de
d'assécher si je puis dire un peu la à
la fois alimentairement et en matière
d'énergie les approvisionnements
énergétiques Taïwan pourrait déjà
suffire à accueillir le fruit qui serait
un peu plus facile à prendre oui
intervenir rapidement parce qu'ils ont
qu'on parle du covid on peut juste faire
mûrir le fruit en intervenant de façon
souterraine à Taïwan et ça c'est quelque
chose qui est très présent notamment par
l'Internet et par toutes sortes de
réseaux qui existent à l'intérieur de
Taïwan donc il y a effectivement un
danger alors le covid pour pour terminer
il nous reste à peu près 6 minutes ça
passe trop vite ce débat mais il est
passionnant c'est c'est bon si je vous
propose une image tiens qu'on a qu'on a
trouvé qui était publié sur sur Twitter
aujourd'hui l'arrestation d'une femme
positive au covid ça se passe à Shanghai
je sais plus si on a cette image oui la
voilà elle est arrêtée mais comme une
dangereuse criminelle quoi
je trouve piraski que ça symbolise assez
bien parce que ce que décrivait Laetitia
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que la
politique covid de la chirurgie qui nous
semble totalement absurde vu d'ici
autrefois un cadre du parti était jugé
sur ses résultats économiques
aujourd'hui il est jugé sur le nombre de
cas de covid et c'est cette inversion
qui qui est en fait qui est siippy est
prêt à son propre piège c'est que
lorsque le covid est donc parti de
Ourane la Chine a crié victoire des le
bois de février et ensuite c'est arrivé
chez nous
en Europe d'abord puis aux États-Unis
avec plus d'un million de morts aux
États-Unis et la Chine en ces temps
isolé et en ayant réussi à conserver
cette cette fermeture réelle à crier
victoire en disant regardez ces
Occidentaux ces Américains qui sont
incapables de faire face à ce virus
aujourd'hui il est pris à son piège
c'est à dire que il n'a pas voulu du
vaccin
Pfizer ou moderna américain il y a eu
des négociations qui ont été menées pour
produire ces vaccins en Chine on a été à
deux doigts de signer un accord le
groupe fossund qui est un groupe chinois
qui a une branche pharmaceutique a
négocié avec Pfizer il y a eu un véto
politique parce que c'est un vaccin
américain le résultat c'est que le
vaccin chinois n'est pas efficace
aujourd'hui contre les variants au
micro-ondes et donc la Chine ne veut pas
prendre le risque d'avoir un nombre de
morts qui rattraperait celui des
États-Unis on est dans dans un dans un
cauchemar qui est celui de la vanité
d'un régime et de l'idéologie et
aujourd'hui l'application de ces règles
de zéro covid et cauchemardesques ce qui
s'est passé à Shanghai au printemps une
ville de 25 millions d'habitants où les
gens criaient par les fenêtres qui
n'avaient plus à manger
c'était un cauchemar qui a traumatisé
les gens et qui en a poussé un certain
nombre à quitter le pays ou à demander à
quitter le pays ou parler à des
entreprises françaises qui sont
installées en Chine leur cadre chinois
ce qui pourrait être qui ont des
diplômes internationaux etc demande
qu'une seule chose aujourd'hui c'est
parti alors que ces dernières années il
y avait les faits inverse les gens
retournés en Chine elle vient fabrique
évidemment un impact on l'a déjà évoqué
sur l'économie chinoise cette gestion du
covid mais ça a été aussi un moyen pour
renforcer ce contrôle dont on parlait en
début d'émission ça a été une
justification pour surveiller fliquer
pardon de d'être un peu trivial le le
pays la population et accélérer
l'installation de caméra de surveillance
qu'on connaît à travers à travers tout
le pays sans aucun doute ça a permis de
renforcer toute la capacité de contrôle
d'isoler aussi un peu la population
chinoise du reste du monde parce qu'il
faut avouer que sur une période aussi
longue ce sont tous les liens tous les
étudiants chinois qui à travers le monde
qui n'ont pas pu partir les étudiants
qui qui arrivaient en Chine les échanges
professionnels et c'est et on voit que
c'est une distanciation aujourd'hui qui
se sent dans les dans les dans les
perceptions et qui a en fait cette
situation de zéro covid est en train
d'infuser sur la Chine de manière très
profonde parce que même sur la pour
revenir à la question du moral des
Chinois le simple fait que il ne puisse
pas circuler se rencontrer à des
incidents sur le nombre de mariages et
sur la démographie alors que la Chine a
appelé à faire plus d'enfants et un vrai
problème de vieillissement de la
population les femmes ne veulent plus
faire d'enfants elles sont tellement
pessimistes sur l'évolution du pays que
aujourd'hui on voit chuter complètement
les naissances et ça s'accélère sous
pendant cette période de zéro covid
Jean-Philippe déjà pour pour conclure il
y a ce qu'on appelle le Crédit Social
c'est ça en Chine donc ça ça rejoint
cette surveillance un peu généralisée
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer en
quelques mots comment ça marche c'est un
peu compliqué parce que crédit social
n'est pas aussi
efficace que on leur raconte souvent si
vous voulez simplement c'est que toutes
vos actions sont
qui ont quelque chose de public sont
enregistrés si vous traversez hors des
clous vous avez ça vient se mettre sur
votre vous perdez des points en quelque
sorte des points sur votre vous savez
c'est quelque chose qui existait déjà il
y avait le dossier sous ma route et dans
son dossier on avait toutes les actions
qui étaient la différence c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a quelque chose qui
est modernisé on a la technologie vous
savez wedding Chan en 1979 demandait la
cinquième modernisation la démocratie ce
qui s'est passé la modernisation c'est
celle de la surveillance qui a eu lieu
et donc aujourd'hui vous êtes donc tout
ce que vous faites c'est si vous si vous
remboursez pas une dette si vous écrivez
la personne qui a mis des banderoles sur
le pont de ce tronc celle-là elle a un
très mauvais crédit social vous perdez
des points et après dans votre vie
quotidienne ça peut avoir des incidences
vous pouvez pas acheter un billet
d'avion vous pouvez pas Espagne
disons que ce n'est pas aussi centralisé
on peut le dire mais il y a une volonté
le covid a été extrêmement utile pour ça
pour renverser cette surveillance et je
crois que la surveillance on est en
train dans le totalitarisme du 21e
siècle dans le totalitarisme 2.0 et je
crois que c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement inquiétant on a vu les
Ouigours tout de même les wigos et les
casars qui sont enfermés uniquement
parce qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont et
aujourd'hui la surveillance compte
concerne l'ensemble des Chinois donc le
justement sera-t-il possible d'avoir des
échanges l'offier contre la société
civile a été d'autant plus efficace que
on est sous un système de surveillance
pratiquement absolu mais juste juste un
espoir il y a toujours des trous dans
les rats dans la raquette et ben
espérons le merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat qui était
vraiment passionnant je vous dis à
bientôt sur sur Public Sénat je vous
donne rendez-vous demain évidemment pour
un nouveau numéro de sens public 18h 22h
et puis votre prochain rendez-vous
politique dans la matinale 8h du matin
Dominique Faure la secrétaire d'État
chargée de la ruralité qui sera l'invité
Oriane monsini belle soirée
[Musique]